[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour un nouveau
numéro du 7-8 échos votre magazine
consacré aux entreprises et à l'économie
locale
focus ce mois ci sur la transformation
digitale des pme tpe et artisans tout de
suite le sommaire associer le travail du
bois au numérique c'est le projet d'un
jeune entrepreneur guyancourt toi
adhérents du skylab à la verrière il
souhaite créer sa menuiserie itinérante
avec des outils numériques et les
machines traditionnelles de l'artisanat
la transformation numérique des tpe pme
est un enjeu parfois vital pour ces
entreprises 1 pourquoi est ce si
important comment réaliser cette
transition nous verrons a aussi que les
banques accompagnent leurs clients dans
cette démarche
enfin retrouvez l'actualité économique
en bref avec les chiffres du chômage
dans les yvelines et le projet auto
pilot sur le véhicule autonome et on
commence ce magazine avec l'illustration
de la transformation numérique dans
l'artisanat après sa reconversion dans
la menuiserie
kevin martin guyancourt toit de 33 ans a
suivi une formation en ligne sur
l'utilisation des outils numériques dans
ce domaine cela en collaboration avec le
skylab de la verrière
il souhaite lancer son activité un
atelier de menuiserie itinérante les
images sont signés rémi lefebvre
on va aller travailler en fait là dessus
je vais m'en servir de base pour
imprimer mes cartes de visite à l'aide
de l'imprimante laser
cette hausse skylab de la verrière qu'il
nourrit son projet sa passion menuisier
de profession kevin martin fabrique des
cartes de visite en bois à l'aide du
numérique il peut travailler cette
matière d'une manière innovante
là on a donc une représentation
vectorielle en fait des passages qui on
voit elle fait du laser et ensuite je
vais déterminé justement où est-ce qu'on
coupe où est-ce qu'on répondra ve avec
les différents codes couleurs les zones
noires seront découpés les parties en
rouge grave est connecté à la découpeuse
laser l'ordinateur lance la réalisation
du projet le résultat est obtenu en
quelques minutes grâce au numérique dans
l'idée que j'en ai et intérêts un peu
plus justement d'éléments personnel et
personnalisé intégré justement par
exemple ces éléments scellement
informatique dans la nouvelles
menuiseries
c'est quelque chose qui pour le moment
est au balbutiement marquage laser
impression 3d plusieurs machines existe
déjà
l'idée de kevin martin rassembler ces
outils dans un atelier de menuiserie
itinérant destiné à des particuliers
individuellement ou en groupes à travers
un système de réservation sur la base un
peu d'un camion tout le monde m'en parle
comme ça mais d'un food truck de la
menuiserie entre guillemets donc pouvoir
justement se rendre auprès du camion que
j'espère créer en fait une sorte d'
applications de géolocalisation et que
les gens souvent puissent venir donc
seul avec soi une idée à réaliser soit
un objet à réparer ou soir justement un
cas doit faire la personnalisation à un
atelier qui sera un peu comme on appelle
un été de recherche et développement
mais pour les particuliers c'est le
principe d'un fablab que je veux a fait
effectivement diffuser ce qui
actuellement beaucoup de choses qui se
fait justement autour de cette
thématique au niveau de l'écologie au
niveau du recyclage de la réparation en
cours de validation de la création de
son entreprise kevin martin va pouvoir
lancer sa démarche de recherche de
financement pour ensuite lancer sa
menuiserie itinérante le 3 février
dernier le gouvernement a annoncé la
labellisation de 80 tiers-lieux les
terres lieux ce sont par exemple des
espaces de coworking
fab lab en résumé des lieux
d'initiatives collectives c'est le cas
notamment du skylab de la verrière il a
reçu le label fabriques numériques de
territoire avec un financement de 100
mille euros à la clé dans cet espace les
adhérents peuvent utiliser des outils
numériques comme des imprimantes 3d une
découpeuse laser ou une brodeuse
numérique comme vous avez pu le voir
dans le sujet précédent
la transformation numérique des petites
et moyennes entreprises et des artisans
devient un enjeu de plus en plus
important alors comment les
entrepreneurs dans ce type de sociétés
utilise-t-il les outils numériques en
quoi c'est un enjeu vital pour leurs
activités
les éléments de réponse avec jean
philippe desranleau consultant formateur
en numérique au 6 9
c'est une fédération patronale française
rattaché à la ceppm regarder la
transformation numérique pour les tpe
pme artisans consiste à s'approprier les
bénéfices que vont pouvoir tirer ces
professionnels des différents outils
numériques qui correspondent à leur
métier pour le commerçant ça va être de
pouvoir faire de la vente en ligne pour
des clients qui sont peut-être pas
proximité de chez eux de façon à pouvoir
élargir son sa clientèle un des
meilleurs moyens pour faire sa
transition numérique et de regarder ce
que font ses confrères et le deuxième
c'est de se documenter et de suivre
éventuellement soit des tutoriels soit
des formations en ligne
les artisans qui ne s'approprie pas le
numérique aujourd'hui risque de se faire
une bêtise et parce qu'ils vont le faire
donc ça peut être une question de survie
et les outils numériques qui permettent
de faciliter le collaboratif sont plus
en plus important les réseaux sociaux y
contribuer notamment et ça beaucoup
d'entreprises aujourd'hui n'ont pas
conscience de l'importance que ça peut
en france le coût de la compétence
informatique et de 8500 euros par an par
salarié
ce chiffre a tout simplement été obtenue
en regardant en étudiant quel était le
temps perdu par les salariés dans les
entreprises faire une tâche quand ils ne
connaissaient pas bien l'outil
informatique qui leur permettait de bien
faire cette tâche ou de la faire
rapidement
c'est l'un des principaux acteurs du
secteur bancaire à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la banque
populaire val de france implantée à
montigny le bretonneux dans ses
différents services elle propose
notamment un accompagnement pour les tpe
pme et artisans dans le cadre de leur
transformation numérique nous avons
rencontrés lors brugnon responsable
adjoint du marché des professionnels et
des entreprises à ce sujet regardez
leurs brouillons bonjour moi je alors
vous êtes responsable adjoint du marché
des professionnels et des entreprises
sur le site banque populaire val de
france de saint quentin en yvelines
aujourd'hui on va parler transformation
numérique des pme tpe et des artisans
ce sont vos clients ou comment vous est
saisi de cet enjeu bien écouter
effectivement la banque claire val de
france la transformation digitale est un
sujet qui nous intéresse c'est important
pour nous inciter nos clients à prendre
le virage de la transformation digitale
on a constaté finalement des nouveaux
comportements des nouvelles technologies
chaque jour nous passons trois heures
sur nos téléphones mobiles à faire des
achats à consulter les réseaux sociaux à
faire des recherches en 2019 on a passé
la barre des 10 mhz des 100 milliards
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires sur
internet
c'est 10% du commerce de détail en
france 40 millions de dhs acheteurs
français et seulement 20% de nos
entreprises vente sur internet
donc pour nous en fait
keith un partenaire des professionnels
et des pme c'est important de leur
parler de ce sujet ils doivent revoir
leurs relations avec les clients tant
digital que finalement physique c'est un
enjeu que vous avez saisi depuis combien
de temps je dirais que ça fait deux
trois ans que on est vraiment sur ce
sujet concrètement ça se passe comment
quand vous recevez une entreprise qui
demandent justement du capital vous l'a
conseillé directement sur la
transformation numérique
alors finalement nous sommes nous sommes
aller par étapes la première chose que
nous avons faite c'est que nous avons
sensibilisé tous nos conseillers de
clientèle à aux enjeux de la
transformation digitale
donc c'est un sujet effectivement qu'ils
abordent un rendez vous avec leurs
clients
et nous avons également développé une
gamme complète de solutions pour
accompagner nos clients dans la
transformation digitale donc avec eux
nous évoquons leur visibilité sur
internet
nous les aidons donc finalement être
plus visibles à aller chercher des
nouveaux clients nous parlons aussi de
chiffre d'affaires sur internet de vente
sur internet avec la création de sites
marchands et puis également nous leur
proposons une solution marketing digital
pour fidéliser leurs clients ont
naturellement tout ça c'est un petit peu
des dépenses et nous finançons ses
dépenses de transformation digitale
vous venez de le dire vous conseillez
d'abord vos clients dans leur démarche
de transformation numérique mais
finalement votre coeur de métier c'est
le financement et je crois savoir que
vous proposez le pré socama dans le
cadre de la transformation numérique et
digital effectivement cette
transformation numérique elle n'est pas
gratuite donc nos clients professionnels
commerçants artisans et entreprises
engagent des dépenses de logiciels d pas
parfois des dépenses immatérielles et
donc nous avons une solution de
financement qui s'appelle le prêt socama
transformation numérique qui est un prêt
qui permet de limiter les garanties
personnelles est totalement dédié à cet
objet pourquoi vous êtes saisis de cet
enjeu finalement banque populaire val de
france
encore une fois la volonté d'accompagner
nos clients on est bon qu'ils historique
des commerçants artisans première banque
des pme
on ne pouvait pas ne pas prendre ce
virage avec eux de la transformation
numérique et ne pas s'adapter à leurs
besoins
est ce que vous avez eu quelques
exemples concrets d'accompagnement alors
oui j'en ai j'en ai en tête
il s'agit d'un restaurateur qui est tout
près d'ici qui nous a sollicités pour
l'aider à fidéliser sa clientèle
donc nous avons une solution marketing
digital qui permet en fait de se
constituer un fichier clients associées
à la carte bancaire grâce à ça et se
constituer un fichier clients et puis
ensuite il peut envoyer des sms ou bien
des emailings pour proposer des offres
promotionnelles et les faire revenir
dans son restaurant et ainsi augmenter
son chiffre d'affaires on a l'exemple
d'un restaurateur dans les différentes
expériences dans les différents cas que
vous avez pu observer
quels sont les secteurs qui sont plus
demandeurs justement de transformation
digitale
ça concerne vraiment tous les
professionnels et toutes les entreprises
donc ya pas un secteur qui est plus
intéressé qu'un autre mais j'ai un autre
exemple en tête il s'agit d'une ferme
qui dans le 78 et qui nous a sollicités
parce qu'elle avait la volonté
développer son chiffre d'affaires en
circuit court
donc on l'a aidé à créer son site
internet et à rendre ce site marchand
est donc là encore une fois on souhaite
accompagner nos clients dans le
développement de leur chiffre d'affaires
qu'est ce que permet la transformation
digitale pour vos clients justement plus
de productivité plus de clients plus de
clients plus de visibilité visibilité
plus d'adaptation aux nouveaux
comportements des consommateurs
vraiment accompagné la tendance
des nouvelles règles de consommation
leur bouillon merci beaucoup merci à
vous responsable adjointe du marché des
professionnels et des entreprises chez
banque populaire val de france baisse du
chômage véhicule autonome ou cyber
attaque s'est tout de suite l'actuel co
en bref dans les yvelines
la baisse du chômage se poursuit dans
les yvelines le département affiche un
taux de chômage de 6,6 pour cent d'après
les chiffres de l'insee
un des plus faibles de france d'après
les données de pôle emploi le nombre de
demandeurs d'emploi sans activité a
diminué de 1,3 pour cent en 2019
une baisse qui atteint les 0,6 pour cent
toutes catégories confondues c'est un
projet européen auto pilot va permettre
de développer des solutions autour du
véhicule autonome des recherches menées
depuis 2010 est sur six sites de
développement
les résultats ont été présentés le 6
février dernier à versailles satory au
mobile app de bd comme utilisation de
l'internet des objets connexion entre
les objets plusieurs perspectives de
développement le 30 janvier le site
bouygues construction a été victime
d'une cyber-attaque une attaque à
travers un rom ce noir un logiciel
malveillant permettant de prendre en
otage des données informatiques
les pirates demandent une rançon de 10
millions d'euros deux semaines après
l'attaqué le système d'information de
bouygues construction fonctionnerait
partiellement ça nous apprend que
personne n'est à l'abri c'est à dire que
si effectivement une attaque est capable
de pénétrer les défenses de bouygues
construction
elle est capable de pénétrer les
défenses de la cazine importe quasiment
n'importe quelle entreprise en france et
donc toutes les entreprises en france on
dirait dans leur responsabilité de
prendre des mesures pour être capable de
répondre à ce type de menace et d'être
capable justement de garantir leur
capacité à redémarrer rapidement
l'activité après une attaque de ce type
aucune défense n'est parfaite il faut au
moins investir dans la capacité à
redémarrer
pour pouvoir assurer la pérennité de
l'entreprise un lieu le vélodrome
national 200 entreprises et cinq mille
offres d'emploi combinée tout cela et
vous obtenez le sky emploi en piste
cévennes cet événement se déroulera le
jeudi 27 février 2020 pour des
informations ou si vous êtes demandeur
d'emploi vous pouvez encore vous
inscrire sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
nous avoir suivis et à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]